please be seated
right thank you very much indeed
um
I'm just going to ask my director
Katie cross to do a short
well correct yes whatever it may be I'm
sure you're excited thank you would you
mind standing please
um I should explain first of all
Victoria is having a knee operation and
cannot stand it's perfectly alright
Victoria
so I haven't
a no prayer
to God much has happened since we last
met
our government has new leadership our
Sovereign Queen Elizabeth has died and
her son Charles has become king
we will remember her late Majesty with
affection and gratitude and give thanks
for her unswerving Devotion to us and to
our country
we pray for our Sovereign Lord King
Charles III as he begins his Reign for
all the royal family that continue to
mourn as they pick up their new duties
may they know your comfort and peace in
all that they do
we lift the members of this Council to
you and The Business of this meeting
we pray that as Leaders they would work
for the good of The Wider community
seeking Justice and hope for all
we pray for ears to listen well to one
another and to hear different points of
view
May their combined expertise and
judgment direct their contributions so
they would be full of wisdom and
thoughtful reflection
may they always have in mind your will
for the well-being and the future of our
community in the name of Jesus Christ
amen thank you very much
thank you member said please
well first thing I'd like to do is
welcome
our students and teachers from hazela
primary school
they've been here for a little while now
and I did you enjoy the debate you had
guys
it was very good wasn't it thank you
very much for participating very good
okay um
Mr Butler would you like to please
um give us apologies for absence please
thank you chairman apologies have been
received from councilors Curtis Eden and
Kendall thank you thank you
members and officers
um I'm inviting anyone to make a
declaration of Interest please
are there any Declarations of Interest
chairman um in relation to the
appointment of the return officer I'd
like to declare an interest on behalf of
myself as a personal interest and also
that of David Dolby and Mason Nash and
in relation to item
13 on the agenda in relation to the
proposal to appoint the section 1.1
officer would have to make apologies
here for Richard Burrell we'll all be
absent for those respective items thank
you thank you very much indeed
um I'd like now to ask if members are
happy with the minutes of meeting if so
can I get a proposal for those minutes
please thank you Council fielding and a
second
all those happy with the minutes
thank you very much
right
um
announcement
are we
ready uh Liz have you got I'm going to
do a few highlights because it's been
quite a time since uh our last meeting
which was on the uh when was it 11th of
July which is an awful long time ago an
awful lot has happened in that period uh
Liz have you got the power okay ready
foreign
I'll just make a note if I may members I
was very distressed to hear that some of
our counselors have been verbally abused
uh this is unacceptable
council's volunteers who want to do the
right thing for their communities
just because someone doesn't agree with
their
decision
it doesn't give them the right to abuse
them
perhaps this is a lack of Tolerance in
society and we are seeing it in other
areas in other fields and perhaps it's
due to covet I don't know but it is not
something that we should accept
I expect I ask members if they are
exposed to any abuse that they should be
reported to the appropriate authorities
you will have the support of this
Council in that
I believe this chamber sets a very high
standard on how debates and the
inevitable disagreements that we have
occur
we should conduct ourselves
as the decor decorously and not
abusively
I think this chamber is an example to be
set for others as well around thank you
ah right go there if he goes that's a
bit more like it
thanks very much indeed
go to the go to the first slide Liz
no first slide I want to see Kate
keep going back can't I said keep going
right that'll start there then that's
fine no the first one that's it hey got
there
thank you right
as I mentioned it's quite a lot going on
these are the highlights I happen to add
and I think to yourself I'm quite lucky
in that uh I'm not as busy as cancer
Cleve
so we do know right first slide please
the uh very interesting one for me I've
always enjoyed uh work with the
um university of Warwick we've been
invited to the degree congregations next
slide please
uh due to covid the graduates were
unable to receive their degrees during
the 20 20 21. so the university put well
I can only describe and you can just see
it in the background the second Slide
the biggest tent I've ever seen
it was absolutely huge and they put
through the 4 000 student graduates uh
for over a two-week period and they
received their degrees it was quite an
amazing thing they also put on a fun
fair as well so for all the um the
parents and friends that were supporting
them next slide please
uh he was invited to the game fair and I
had the honor of being presented to uh
Princess Anne
uh she's now decided that she will be
the patron of the basc which is a
shooting Association
uh the game fair is fascinating I mean
it's amazing amount of money is spent
over a three-day period and also that
the week afterwards as well and some of
the things next slide please there's
you'll be surprised you can buy at the
game fair now I'm not sure I want one of
those in my garden but you never know
and it's only twenty thousand pounds
next slide please
now this is something you don't see in
Evesham High Street every day is uh the
it's a reenactment of the battle beisham
uh very interesting and I learned an
awful lot about the reactment societies
and such like uh I don't people know but
uh the Battle of Egyptians in 1265 and
it's a pivotal battle
where some of the month was eventually
killed and of course it shaped the
course of our history as a country
next slide please
the mayor and I were invited to the 75th
anniversary of the founding of the state
of Pakistan
uh it's been enjoyable time and
especially the male afterwards a very
very nice Curry and I think Council clay
will agree we had a very interesting
musical interlude
foreign
thank you next slide
this one was great fun this is the young
traders of the Year Awards which is now
an annual event in Stratford uh and it
was lovely to see all these uh younger
people everyone's younger than me
meeting them all and especially some of
them who just started their businesses
up over covid or during covert so it's a
really inspirational time
the uh I'd like to say thanks to Dermot
of LSD markets and for their enthusiasm
in setting up this event as well
next slide please
well obviously to say it was great
sadness we heard the death of Queen
Elizabeth
the second
um I will say that it was a fluid time
during that period And I'd say thank you
very much indeed to all the staff that
helped out tremendously things are
changing literally on the day
the arrangements made were very short
notice and uh
you know it wasn't was an interesting
period I had the privilege of reading
out the proclamation uh at the Town Hall
and attended a number of Civic events on
behalf of the period the council over
that period next slide please
this was a nice one
um these are the Carver volunteer Awards
uh as I'm about to do at Stratford town
it's always humbling to meet so many
people who volunteer their time on
selfishly
to help others
I think that the bonus of it was that I
was able to hand out two Awards to two
Societies in Ulster who had
um won that evening as well next slide
please
yeah that was the mop Fair we had some
fun opening that and going on the right
I tried to get a few of the others on
there councilor cleave wouldn't do it no
those Council off she wouldn't do it
either yeah
try to get you on
however it was great fun and I must
admit the oxygen ride I needed oxygen
afterwards
and I should say on the the right hand
side there's the vicar Patrick
uh of Trinity and uh his robes were
literally he said he felt like an angel
flying through this through the air with
his robes or fluttering around
finally and just one side at a time Liz
first slide please that's it thank you
hold that uh this was a lovely thing
there's a company in Ulster called cow
Gavin may not have heard of them they're
a world leader in heat exchanger
technology they they export 90 goes
abroad and they are now expanding and
they're building a purpose-built
Factory in the industrial estate in
Ulster and they are partnering with the
University of Warwick and they are
embedded the honestly are embedded in
the actual
um
business of tech as technology which is
I'm not being funny Cutting Edge World
leading uh okay then next slide please
uh Nadeem came along and um he's uh
digging a hole
I'm not quite sure what for who for but
anyway it was a very nice event thank
you very much indeedless
right
chief executive
would you like to oh sorry Tony first I
was going to get you down here
Tony first thank you chair
um
I did attend the commemoration service
for her majesty Queen Elizabeth in
Warwick
I also attended the RSC showing of the
funeral and there were about 500 people
present in the RSA which I thought was a
really excellent turnout
um
I've been to meetings of Coventry and
Warwickshire local Enterprise
partnership and the finance and
governance committee I would normally
think these are routines I wouldn't
announce them but these meetings were
really about how we are going to wind up
the let because the lap will actually
cease operations I think March next year
and finally uh there was a meeting at
Warwickshire County Council a week
before last with the leaders of the
boroughs and districts and the County
Council and the chief execs to discuss
what we might do collectively about the
cost of living crisis thank you thank
you very much
thank you um two announcements from me
today uh firstly an update on the sound
system so as members will be aware the
council is in the process of tendering
for replacement sound system it's being
led by Richard our head of resources
given the scale of the expenditure we're
obliged to go through a proper
procurement process and therefore that
is taking some time until the new system
is ready we will be continuing to use
the wired system that you've got today
so apologies for the the wires across
the the floor it is expected though that
the replacement system will be
implemented in time for the budget
meeting of council which will be held on
the 27th of February
secondly on behalf of staff and myself I
just wanted to say a few words in
relation to Graham aspin who died
following a period of illness from
cancer on the 17th of August age just
64. Graham worked for the council for
almost his entire working career he
actually started at the council as a car
park attendant back in 1982 and worked
in admin before moving into Democratic
services and and the election show that
we all came to know and love him in
Graham was one of the most respected
officers within the council and was
universally popular with elected members
staff and any external body that he came
across as most notably the town and
Parish councils across the district
Graham was extraordinarily hard working
knowledgeable and conscientious also a
very private man in himself
Graham never gave up his fight against
cancer and it was my privilege to
present Graham with his 40-year service
certificate on the 20th of July just a
few weeks before he unfortunately passed
I'm sure that you'll all agree with me
when I say that Graham will be sorely
missed across the whole of the council
finally I Graham didn't want any fuss
whatsoever following his passing but we
we couldn't we couldn't have that um so
we had a cake sale in his honor um on
the 29th of September where we raised an
incredible 644 pounds which we donated
to cancer Charities thank you chairman
thank you very much
right the next item and then the agenda
is public participation
uh we've received three questions from
two members of the public uh Mr Tom Ross
from the tanworth has readers
Association and one for Mr Lee Rhodes
also in attendance uh can I ask Mr Ross
first of all please if you would like to
uh to your opinion now hold on a second
there's a microphone over there for you
uh comes the Cargill
I feel I'm going to sing because the
Cargill oh what kinds of this
um my question relates to limited infill
within the mppf and it was asking the
residents would like to know why within
Tamworth lsv The Village not the parish
why most of the applications seem to be
granted without any apparent reference
to either the scale
of limiting the scale or living limiting
the totality of a number of applications
so the reply came back and I'm grateful
to councilor shenton and uh his team uh
we totally accept that the council wants
consistency of decision making and that
planners want discretion no argument at
all in that point
but lpas do individually clarify
individual points of policy Warwick
District Council has if I'm allergic to
mention them uh and this Council had a
30 rule for many years which eventually
got rid of
so my argument the residents feel is
that the the repetition of the council
is very good in so many areas but
Plumbing's the one which seems to let
you down according to it so if
I could say that we were talking about
the village not the parish that was my
fault I apologize so what we'd like to
know is
could you provide the figures for
Tamworth Village LSP a number of
applications granted and refused and
could you tell us who in planning is
responsible for looking at the overall
cumulative effect of lots of different
applications for limited insult we're
trying to find out what the limit is
thank you
Council shantan would you like to
respond to them
councilor Ross even for the the question
I understand we've we've uh you you're
expecting an answer based on the on the
The Village rather than the town we'll
take that away and I'll have to come
back to you obviously it's not something
that I've got available to me at my
fingertips and I've made a note of of
your follow-up question as well so I'll
come back to you on both of those
um hopefully when I next see you which I
think is probably Thursday at the at the
parish council meeting
thank you you have a second question did
you want to
the second question relates to the
monies which Stratford District Council
received because of a legacy clawback
Clause when local Authority housing
lock-ups garages species were given I
assume to work sure Seth Workshop
Housing Association and subsequently
transferred to orbit
uh now we've had this relates to several
applications in bellfield and it's not
unrelated to the previous question
because the question relates to
cumulative effect
now we've now had two sales and I know
from the from the response uh councilor
Barker gave that she didn't have
um individual figures for disposal of
garages well I can tell you that
the disposal of the first sale of garage
and lock-ups in Tamworth was very
controversial in the village the parish
council tried to buy it and it went for
a very very substantial sum
fifty percent of which I understand came
to this Council so it would be useful to
know if you don't know we'll happily
provide those figures from the auction
here
it arises again because there is an
another disposal has taken place of the
very last bit of parking in the
bellfield and the residents are up in
arms about an already bad situation made
worse by our bits selling the land that
was previously sold and now uh orbit
have again sold it for housing
so again we're concerned about the
totality the number of applications and
also about the fact that parking is one
of these little things that is an
afterthought it seems to us in the
planning process if watch your highways
doesn't particularly raise an objection
it seems to get noddied through the
total effect of these applications on
the bill field on the residence and on
the Bowling Club who bring in lots of
extra people at just towards time has
been catastrophic and if this next one
goes ahead it will lose six more species
and what we'd like is some of the money
councilor Barker which you've got
started if we're in the general uh
uh Capital receipts to come tamil's way
so I would ask you to reconsider the
the no thank you thank you very much
Council Parker did you want to respond
does this switch itself
um thank you for the question I I think
it was um as fully answered as it
possibly can be because
uh the guidance is set out in part over
the development requirements
um and we also
um apply the funds to the general
Capital program and that's just what we
do so if there are things that come
forward in Tamworth to be applied for
then those projects will of course be
looked at but other than that that's
just what happens to that money plus
um
the the comment you make about
Warwickshire County Council I
there are very very specific
requirements on them as to what they can
and can't comment on in terms of
Highways and may I suggest that perhaps
the your Parish Council has a
conversation with them so that they can
understand how when and why they object
thank you thank you
right um we now have Mr Rhodes thank you
um your your question has been answered
do you have a supplementary that you
would like to ask I do indeed thank you
thank you to councilor Jefferson for his
first answer
my supplementary is
in light of the lib dem's criticism in
their Arden by-election literature
regarding the waste of 320 000 pounds
resulting from the collapse of the
merger can you confirm the public record
that shows libden counselors Curtis Eden
I fragile Jay fraggley junid their
leader her together they're part of
parliamentary candidate and councilor
Rock voted for the merger and that no
liberal Democrats voted against the
merger on the 13th December 21.
Council Jefferson would you like to
respond
thank you for your question Mr Rhodes
um I am sure you are absolutely correct
in what you said
thank you very much indeed that's the
end of public participation
um I'm going to suggest perhaps now that
our friends from the Hazel School
might now wish to depart before we head
into the debate have you all had a good
time
good bye-bye
thank you
[Applause]
[Laughter]
good
Penny until late she's with doctor's
appointment yes just making out from
another place
okay thank you
yeah promotion it's just been advised
that um Council O'Donnell is running
late and should be attended later in the
meeting thank you thank you
right I would now like to uh go to item
six on the agenda
um I would like to invite Council
Jefferson uh to introduce the annual
report on the state of the district
council Jefferson
thank you chair
uh before I start on the report I'd like
to thank Melanie Jeffrey and Simon
purfield for their hard work in
producing this report
I would just like to say that in looking
at this report
I would just comment that we live in
Fairly turbulent uncertain unpredictable
and volatile times
we've had covered
there's been the war in Ukraine which
has been one of the driving forces
behind inflation and the cost of living
crisis
all this has left and he's still leaving
scars on society and the economy and
this report reflects some of those scars
uh if one looks at paragraph one three
it says the results of this debate will
amongst other things be considered by
the leader in proposing the budget and
policy framework of the council for 23
24.
I would just like to set expectations on
that score
there is no money
um
not only that not all of the things in
this report can Stratford on Urban
District Council influence and I think
it's very important to note that some
need other agencies to actually pursue
them
well
if we turn to uh
paragraph three we now have a population
in the district of 134 700.
if we look at the population
increase between the but the censuses of
2011 and 2021 the population increased
by 11.8 percent
that is obviously very significant
increase
if we look at the numbers
on figure one
particularly over the years
2017-18 to 2021
if that level of growth continues then
by 2031 the district could be close to
160 000 in population
anything close to that will bring a
significant number of challenges
and I wouldn't like people to win that
underestimate what those challenges will
be
our population is very weighted towards
the older end of the scale
and that brings more challenges with it
as the older end of the scale tends to
cost more in terms of services and in
terms of health
foreign
section 4 on housing
the number of households in the district
is 62 200 that was in 2021.
uh we know as it says in paragraph four
three house prices are high and in all
honesty they are unaffordable for many
uh we can look at the median house
prices
and they are well above the Warwickshire
average and the reality actually is as I
said they're unaffordable for many and
in all honesty there is little the
district council can do to impulse house
prices
like I said house prices are high median
house price to median earnings and I'm
looking at paragraph 441
uh the median house price to median
earnings ratio
10.17 in 2021 lower quartile 10.74
it does reinforce the point that house
price you really are unaffordable for
many
figure four and you'll see a significant
drop off in the number of housing
completions in 20 20 21 and that was
down to covid so it's obvious that kobit
has had a significant impact on activity
in the district
one really good point is I Empower 464
affordable housing is made up an average
of 29 of all new dwellings completed
since 2012. that actually I think is
quite an achievement and one of which we
should be proud
uh
total number of recorded crimes
7343 in the year to June 22.
and we really do have a lower rate of
crime across the district compared to
other areas
[Applause]
if we move on to section 6 employment
and qualifications uh
we have 1900 people as at March 22
clusters unemployed three percent of the
economically active population we have a
very low levels of unemployment compared
to other areas
and in March 22
there were 12 400 people clusters
economically inactive 17.6 of all 16 to
64 year olds
uh the economic inactivity rates been
around that level for the last 20 years
that compares with the national picture
where economic activity is increasing
if we look at a section
six three
we are a well-paid area no doubts about
that gross weekly earnings in 21 for
full-time workers
676 pounds 10.
higher than the average the West
Midlands at 581.80 and Great Britain is
613 10.
uh if we look at section 6-5 employment
and by industry
it says in 652 manufacturing accounts
are the largest number of jobs at 12 000
representing 17.3 percent of total jobs
in the district
I I have to say that we're not quite the
hive of manufacturing activity that that
jobs do to May indicate because a lot of
those are at jlr Gaiden and those jobs
tend to be professional and white collar
not actual Hands-On manufacturing so I
just thought I'd make that clear
if we look at 654
and this one does really indicate the
extent to which kovit has affected the
local economy
uh according to the 2021 tourism
economic impact assessment
6628 tourism jobs in the district
uh this is much lower than previous
year's figures
and there's a direct result of covid
and tourism equates to eleven and a half
percent of all employment in the
district
and there is no doubt about it tourism
is being very very slow to recover from
those impacts uh particularly uh
International tourism
uh paragraph 711
manufacturing the cancer over a third of
gross value added in the district
one and a half billion
so it's big
and real estate combined to
manufacturing accounts for half of the
gross value added in the economy
it does mean that the district's economy
is perhaps less resilient
than had we got a somewhat better
balanced economy
and I have to say that's one of the
reasons why we put an awful lot of
effort into Economic Development
what we really want is a more resilient
economy
we want growth in gva we want well-paid
jobs and all of these are important to
the well-being of our residents
if we now look at
735 which is still on industry and
Industrial structure
agriculture forestry and fishing account
for
8.9.8.9 percent of gva
it's his own surprising given we are a
largely rural area
but again if you start to look at what
is coming down the track in terms of
food security that could well turn out
to be a very important area of activity
if we look at health
then as a district our people are in
Better Health compared to the England
average life expectancy in 2019 85 years
for women
compared to England 83 and for men 81.4
compared to the average for England of
79.4 we have the best life expectancy in
the West Midlands
if we start to look at section 9 poverty
this is an interesting one because there
is no doubt the world has changed
because of the uh war in Ukraine
Energy prices have spiked
uh food prices have also risen
significantly and in all honesty there's
not a lot the government could do about
those price increases we are spending
tens of billions in uh helping people
with their energy bills and although the
level of support May well change next
April as we heard today
but it will cushion the impact on the
households and businesses to some extent
I have to say as a personal view I see
little chance of energy prices subsiding
in the near future
there is a comment about recyclologies
in interest rates by the bank of England
and the results of the fall in the pound
have made the outlook for household
Finance is even Bleaker that's
absolutely right
and I think the inter increasing
interest rates has come as a shock to
many
and it doesn't represent the end of a
period when interest rates have been
unsustainably and in all honestly
damagingly low
turning to uh 9-3 fuel poverty
it really is a very uncomfortable truth
that if real Energy prices increase
massively more and more people will be
defined as being in fuel poverty
that's just the way the calculation goes
and I think people should remember that
we are saying that energy prices have
tripled
what is not surprising a lot more people
will be defined as being fueled poor
to move on now to section 11.
uh Stratford District Council residency
2022
uh 86 percent of those surveyed are
satisfied with their local areas a place
to live although he's down five
percentage points it's hard to know what
impact Kirby might have had
I didn't look at what people say the
five most important things we can
somewhere a good place to live
uh the key ones are the level of crime
and Health Services
if we look at what people think about
their local area indicate the things
that need improving Road and pavement
repairs are top level of traffic
congestion is second
that it isn't a great deal we can do
directly about those but one of the key
things to note I think is that
infrastructure is not keeping pace
with the growth in the population in the
district
further down that page 41 of residents
tend to agree or strongly agree that
Stratford District Council provides
value for money
and 63 degree a great deal or to some
extent that we are making the local area
a better place to live
so we must be doing something right
uh
if I sorry
if I turn on to page 52 paragraph 12 8.
and that just says the council is clear
we can reasonably expect a period of
continued reductions in support which
you've not addressed would challenge the
financial sustainability of the council
there's no doubt about it inflation will
have a significant impact on the
council's budget
I'd reiterate one of my opening remarks
there is no money
I'm getting good at saying that
uh
if you look at some of the achievements
in 1214
we did sign a contract to create a new
world leading material to recycling
facility
the new restart grants paid to help
businesses reopening after the last
lockdown and we paid out a lot of money
on the many different schemes
uh we pioneered the housing plus Fred
winter Center
a really good initiative
we reaffirmed commitment to tackling
climate change we signed a new 10-year
Leisure management contract with
skewered funding for the local Authority
delivery scheme to help improve Energy
Efficiency low-income households
we awarded ten thousand to refuse to
support domestic abuse Outreach service
where we were awarded 1.2 million from
the additional restrictions Grant to
support businesses not covered by other
Grant schemes
so we have actually done a lot
we've also worked together with Warwick
District councils we worked with act on
energy to promote grants advice and
support available to residents
and we've made further funding available
to Citizens advice to help with the cost
of living crisis
uh in 2021 page 56
we've identified a clear strategy for
the development of the Gateway project
and initiatives on the Gateway project
are still ongoing
uh we give significant expansion
upgrading and modernization of CCTV
we are also supporting Ambitions for
growth at the Wells bone campus and
Quentin Road Technology Center
uh like I said the discretionary uh
sorry the
we developed a support package to help
businesses call Post covered in
particular the 1.2 million where we
worked in conjunction with the growth
hub
we created 135 new jobs and saved 703
Stratford Riverside project and the aim
of that was in part to underpin the
tourist offer is progressing
so
on the very challenging circumstances
I think we've achieved a lot
we've we've laid a firm foundation for
academic growth in the district so we
can all prosper
I would however say that the next two
years at least are going to be very
challenging
we need to be very honest with people
that there's little that Stratford
District Council on its own can do to
protect them from the cost of living
living crisis
and I would just remind people of two
key points
one we can't influence everything or do
everything
and to repeat one of my favorite
favorite phrases there is no money
so in conclusion I would say this year's
report May well be somewhat more
optimistic
the next years
sorry I just couldn't resist that
whoever gives it
and with that I am proposing
that
I don't even district is noted and these
shoes raised will be considered as part
of the budget making process for 23 24.
thank you
um
uh do I have a um no first of all
can I have a second for this
I think I've got a council Fielding over
there uh but would you like to describe
what we're going to be doing now
[Music]
um so um in our rules the form of the
debate that might follow is really a
matter for the leader and the chairman
of the council to decide having said
that traditionally we've always allowed
an opportunity for the leader of the
main opposition group to respond to that
beyond that it's a case of allowing
contributions to have a fair debate you
might want to limit the the the time
allowed for each person that might want
to speak it it probably depends on who
who actually wants to speak and how much
time you're prepared to 30 seconds so
[Laughter]
um so I'll leave it to you thank you
very much in control but certainly the
lead with the opposition right if I
would ask cancer Junior if you would
like to respond to that thank you
yes indeed I I would
um
I think it's disingenuous quite honestly
to say that everything uh is the fault
of either kovid Ukraine or other or
others
this report suggests that we've not been
addressing some of the key areas of
concern for some years
and there are certainly some what I
might call canaries in the mine issues
that are highlighted here that have had
chance to build up over quite some years
we don't have the same housing stock
pattern as England or even Warwickshire
that's taken some years to achieve
the median house prices
are of great concern to and as has been
said are unaffordable for many
and we don't have the same housing stock
we don't have the same median housing
rentals we'd have the third highest
monthly rentals in Warwickshire and it
says in there that those in the lower
income bracket are affected worse by all
the price Rises that have happened
many of these things have taken many
years to to uh um to come about it's not
just been covered not just being Ukraine
and it's not just the fault of others
what I would like to see is many of the
key lessons that are in this report
being taken seriously and taken on board
both through the local plan and through
the Local Economic strategy going
forward
we have an economy that is Reliant and
has been Reliant for some years on two
sectors
and it says quite clearly on page 39
that the district's economy is less
resilient and more open to threats than
the more balanced economies of districts
such as Warwick and again that has taken
some years for that to have come and
given that we no longer wanting to work
with Warwick it is notable that it is
Warwick that is mentioned in in this one
now one thing that you can say is a
direct a direct outcome of covid-19 is
the devastating impact on tourism
industry
but the fact that we've had an
imbalanced resilient imbalanced economy
for some years and that several others
have had said that we've probably been
playing too much of a Reliance on the
tourism tourism industry for some years
that is only come about made it worse
this last couple of years but it was
there to begin with
most of our businesses are micro
businesses
um again happy to support micro
businesses but we need to support them
to make sure that they grow into healthy
businesses with long-term future
the one thing that is not mentioned in
this state of the economy uh state of
the district report is the health of the
high streets and I do hope that that is
taken on board seriously as we go
forward
it is notable that we've got
significantly fewer children and younger
adults living in the district compared
to the West Midland region and England
as a whole
and again that is has that that has come
about for a number of reasons if you
can't afford a house in the area you
can't afford to live in the area you
can't afford maybe to bring children up
in the area maybe then our schools
suffer our villagers suffer our High
Street suffer and our businesses suffer
and as mentioned we have a population
where we're going to need
people who will be able to work in the
care industry work in the support
industry going forward but they've got
to be able to be housed they don't want
we don't want people that are having to
commute and spend all their money on
commuting rather than on earning a
living within the area
I note the section on in page on page 43
on poverty
and I also note
that we have in the uh in one of the one
of the pages we've got satisfaction with
the Stratford District Council process
on planning applications which have been
falling for 10 years and I think that
this is one area where we really do need
to start concentrating a little bit more
on how our planning process our local
plan
Etc meets the future needs of our
residents it's not just the economic
strategy it's the whole housing
area as well
so just to finish I don't want to kind
of prolong
the agony of pointing out all the
problems that we have in our areas as
well as the good points that we have in
our areas what I want to make sure is
that going forward this District Council
works on its economic strategy works on
its Housing Works on its economic plan
and makes sure and its local plan and
make sure that in the next 10 years we
are delivering for our residents because
certainly we have not delivered for them
over the last 10 years
thank you Council Junior Council Marty
Hawkins
hey and around me I am a details person
and so I've carefully considered this
report before us today and I did want to
bring some details to you
um because I've extrapolated
some facts and figures to do with the
life of women in the district can I
point out that in
6.3.2 it states that the salaries or pay
that women can expect to receive in
Stratford is only 67 of that of men
in section
5.1.3 it clearly indicates with regard
to Crime that the violence and sexual
offenses
um are exponentially higher when
compared to all other crimes in the
district so to say that we have a low
crime is in the majority of the crimes
but in the um violence and sexual
offenses and we know that women are more
likely to be the victims of that crime I
couldn't quite see the graph but it's
stating somewhere in the region between
20 and 25 offenses per 1 000 of
population I'm probably going to have to
um defer to somebody who can use their
toes as well as their fingers to work
out this Mass but that is a staggering
number of offenses when you consider
that's the population is at 134 700 I
make that to be somewhere around the
region of 3 000 offenses in domestic
violence and sexual violence I will
caveat that say that mathematics is not
my strong point reading however is in
section
8.2.3 we are well above the average of
those women being admitted for alcohol
dependency into the hospitals and in
fact that figure
exceeds the figure for men in the
district as well
and that is worrying that's a well above
the national average figure as well
um
I'm also think that if you look at all
of that in the whole
um there could be some some of this
could be linked and I'd also like to
conclude today by saying that in section
3.1.6 it says that this district is made
up of 51 of women and I do hope
counselors across the political Spectrum
will join with me in hoping that the
recruitment process over the next few
months will reflect this and that we
have an equal number of female
counselors with and male counselors
thank you but please be of regard to
what I've said about this district and
women thank you thank you Council
Hawkins right councilor off
um
on page 27 when you look at the number
of dwellings by type
uh you bring in Bungalows but on page 28
you don't look at the median house
prices of Bungalows and bearing in mind
there are 10 of bungalows in the
district and bearing in mind also that
um Bungalows are on pieces of land that
are often twice the size of of houses
and some Bungalows certainly in my world
are going for uh more value money than
some of the big four five bedroom houses
so I just wanted to say I just wondered
why Bungalows were not on that chart on
page 28 thank you
here and make an argument
thank you very much indeed
right uh Council 4G
probably more often than pretty much
every year but just sort of just
focusing on housing I'm sure the
councils have got other points to make
but obviously we know that median has
places in the district of 340 000.
um affordable homes to rent or to buy
the need for social sort of housing
makes
the fact that those house prices are so
high even more important even lower
quartile is still 254 000 in England
it's 185 and warwickshire's 205 000.
uh as councilor Rolfe said there's more
Bungalows and detached houses in
Stratford the mixing Stratford needs to
change uh in in the district and to
reflect the needs of its residents
median house prices to wages again are
it's 10.17 in warranty is 8.55 and
England 8.04
how do the many people working in
Hospitality sector hope to buy or even
rent just 13 of houses are
socially rented
well affordable renting which is
incredibly low
um I'd like to know actually how how
much of that 13 is actually socially
rented which is actually affordable not
affordable
to give low-income families and young
people a district this this really needs
to increase needs to change and continue
to see
um Stratford's District's population
aging with younger people moving out of
the town and older people coming into
the area that's down
primarily not not solely but a big
reason for that is the cost of housing
Council Jefferson said uh there's little
Stratford District Council can do to
change house prices
uh he has a he does have a point but
um if you're building your own houses
surely that's an intervention into the
market and that will make a difference
so once again I think his pessimism
shows the council's lack of ambition
regarding the building of council houses
for local people
also says we should be part of the 29
makeup of affordable housing but social
housing 30 seconds please
um
it's it we don't actually know the
figures when they're actually taken out
and
um it's really important to realize that
living here in a good quality house is
the building block to live a good happy
and healthy life and it's housing that
you start on and everything else follows
thank you thank you very much
um just a note for other people are
going to be speaking tonight Encounters
of today is that some of the questions
are coming out slightly Technical and I
don't expect Council Jefferson to be
able to answer all of those at this
moment so I'm suggesting that we will
take those away and we'll send that
through to everybody
at the appropriate time soon as you've
got all that information so don't expect
necessarily a response immediately but
we will try and get back to you on that
one
right uh Casper dealer
and
can you hold on a second
try again thank you okay thank you
the leader talked about challenges in
relation to population growth where um
if you go
um if you look at paragraph 3.32 well
for the navalness in the greatest
estimated population growth over this
period
and this meant to the Housing
Development as as happened at a high
scale in this rural world made up of
ancient Villages and new settlements
this increase in housing and population
has not been accompanied by an upgrade
or Improvement in infrastructure
in particular drainage and sewage we're
still having drainage research problems
and new residents tell me about the
difficulties to access health services
including GP services and the NHS
dentists
as well as the limited and expensive
public transport system
um so this is something that we need to
tackle and I don't believe that the
council does not have any role I mean
you know our planning our local plan
should
um you know make sure that
infrastructure and services
um are accompanied this Housing
Development and and also I wanted to say
regarding the Ukrainian War
um I want to say how proud I am or well
for Donavon residence who have opened
their homes and their hearts to the
Ukrainian people and I asked the council
for full support
um throughout the placements thank you
thank you
right councilor Jenny friedreich
could you get a little closer to the
microphone please I was particularly
interested
in the uh differential in male and
female and uh median gross weekly
earnings uh for men it's 794 10 while
for women it's 533.40.
I'd be interested in understanding this
done this done for a differential more
accurately it'd be interesting to have
some data on the sectors where men and
women are employed and the drivers to
employ men and women in these sectors is
it education time skills based
also interesting to see the strength of
micro businesses in the district but I'd
be interested in the nature of these
businesses are they service-based
manufacturing financial and to see who
dominate this this area because it seems
to me it's probably more women than men
because they can actually make
businesses
um at home
and therefore perhaps earning earning
less
all women in more employed in part-time
jobs and what are the drivers for that
and is there anything the district can
actually do to make it easier for women
to actually take on
more full-time employment
um I think a number of single households
will be led by by women which actually
puts them into the lower earning bracket
uh right from the very beginning and
what can we do to actually support these
families going into the very very
difficult times that we have ahead of us
as the leader said I think we're in for
extremely tough time over the next two
three four if as as he said 10 years and
I think we need to be looking at making
sure that women
find the way to improve their earning
power thank you thank you Council I
think that was quite an interesting
um discussion
I would suggest that there's an awful
lot you've asked all there I noticed
that Mr purple's at the back and I hope
he's been making lots and lots of notes
am I making the same CSC has I'm making
the same suggestion uh counter poetry
that we respond to those appropriately
because there's some valid points in
there let's let's see if we can tease
all those out today and then hopefully
Mr purple will come back to us on that
one
expecting answers
okay then thank you
Council Ian project
can you hear me
thank you
um this is a 44-page report and I have
to admit that I haven't
read it or word to word as yet but I was
wondering if you could tell me how many
uh people live in the district but work
outside the district
and how many live in stratford-on-avon
town boundary and work outside the town
boundary beating the district or behind
Beyond
because obviously this is going to have
a great impact on our Transport Systems
buses cars and trains Etc thank you
thank you Council project again I think
that's one that we can try and tease out
moons to perfume thank you Council
Bromwich
oh apologize I'm sorry can I just ask
councilor Adam I do apologize categories
you're next
thank you thank you chair
um I'd just slightly disheartened
looking at the priorities of the council
that um
under a number of them the the number of
uh bullet points on progress are fairly
significant apart from when you come to
Priority number four responding to
climate change emergency we have one
bullet point in what we need to do and
one bullet point and the things that
we've done considering that we accept
that this is a significant challenge for
the district uh for the country and for
the world I would have liked to have
seen a bit more
um detail in term what we have done and
what we intend to do to do this
um you know we're talking about housing
that has an impact on uh on climate
change talking about business and
economy that has an impact on climate
change a bit more detail is needed if
we're going to actually do it and that's
when we need to see the actions too
um I also just like to sort of pose a
question I know that this report was um
produced within the few weeks up until
now and as the leader says there's no
money given the the uh the chance of the
exchequer released a new budget uh this
morning does that mean we now have less
than no money
before he answers probably yeah
okay thank you uh now Council Bromwich
well I will start by saying I wonder
people actually did read it page to page
on this when it come through that and I
take some very interesting points out
this
I've noticed a lot of discussion today
about housing
and the price of housing the one thing
that this probably shows as we've had
when the higher house building
proportions in the uh if you break down
councils it's actually lots of house
building doesn't reduce prices it just
tends to mean absolutely you're a very
desirable area and everybody probably
wants to move in there
so what this brings into the question
then is
central government is on about changing
planning regulations which could make it
easier for developers and we've all
mentioned the impacts the developments
have an infrastructure
what we as a council should be doing
however is probably science and central
government as your local council's needs
are the best place people to give their
housing requirements that so when we
look at Stratford district for instance
we know that we do have issues with
social and affordable housing and that
should be a higher priority need than
some nice big expensive houses
it's something that at the moment it's
not in our control really when central
government imposes numbers on us and
says well this is the percentage of
social affordable homes you have to
build it may not address an issue so
that is one example on housing when we
look across the district as a whole
we talk about aging in the district
where it's true that yes you tend to
find in my experience that yes because
we have a high proposal small villages
and small towns we will tend to be in
overpopulation
but if I look at my own experience in
southern in the past 12 months having
taken on I never foster child
you struggle to get school places which
suggests there again
we are starting to get people coming but
it's going to take time to come through
and it's not going to happen everywhere
again this could be down to things like
housing balancing how our building's
gone in the previous few years and it
may well change in the next few years as
other areas are built on so that's
probably so important to take your
account
I also know to think interest about lone
parents being one now who's who's
doubled this quota of children in the
past year having two 14 year olds if I
went by the actual technical definition
I'd be when those things in poverty
but what I would turn around to say is
be very cautious when you use the word
poverty because there are lots of
different levels of poverty
so as a counselor I've been around to
people's houses and they've helped them
out and invariably you tend to find that
when you have these layers of poverty
actually a lot of underlying causes and
poverty is a very general word so when
you hear that word be very careful on
what it really is on the thing it can be
something as simple as somebody's
actually really not very good with their
finances
it could be many many other issues
they've hit hard times Partners left on
many different things but be careful
when we try and say about levels of
poverty in this District or anywhere 30
seconds please well I would say overall
is we know a financial times are tough
the leader knows that I'm one of those
who've been saying that probably for
three or four years
I hate to say it folks but it's not
going to be a couple of years of tough
times it's going to be a fair few years
whoever is sitting in that chair in 12
months time delivering this state
district but as counselors and as a
council we have to make sure we can do
the best for our communities and these
reports are so helpful in giving us
guidance thank you Council Bromwich
Castle Rock
we asked all the questions because I'm
very impressed with his skilled by
numbers
Finance person and uh
knowledgeable in that department anyway
um
just picking a few points of the report
which uh as Council Obama says he's very
interested in and makes interest in
Reading uh just picking a few points out
here I would say beware of averages so
on 6.3.1 for those of us that represent
rural areas you know agricultural
workers are well below these averages so
you know it does mask
uh the situation of people just because
it's high average earnings doesn't mean
it's everywhere particularly in rural
areas
um
then I I I've said this at previous
state of the districts and the leader
did
refer to jlr and the effect it has which
is clumped together as manufacturing of
course I I am a chartered engineer so
I'm always interested in this but I'm
not quite sure why something to do with
this standard industry classification
codes
you know I looked at the people that did
this at the back but um we put put in
that it which a Professional Services
really into manufacturing and I think
that that clumps the numbers together
and it doesn't give us a completely
accurate picture in doing that
um
then when uh it it under section 9 in
poverty
and I I was listening to this on the
radio today and it
to me this is a a felony that gets
repeated time and time again with the
energy prize cap and they keep talking
about these numbers which this is
repeated in here are the glob numbers of
the average
household electricity and gas bill
the energy prize cap worked on the unit
price of electricity
and this is what we I think we could do
our bit here we need to tell people
that's what it is it's a cap on kilowatt
hours
and we need to get people to think about
energy conservation and we are
said a moments ago we're weak on
encouraging people to do that where we
can helping them to do that we need to
do more helping people to conserve
energy and you know energy is never
going to go down so let's do that when
we talk about things let's not talk
about these average numbers 30 seconds
please and a couple of things
um and that's reflected in the uh
Central Heating and and finally I would
say it's a a bit worrying that 30 only
31 of people agree they can influence
decisions in their local area and I
think that's something we need to work
upon thank you very much Jim thank you
Council Ross uh Council Barker
thank you uh most of what I want to say
actually is on housing um but I would
point out that we have another notice of
motion where housing will be coming up
and multiple questions on the green
papers about housing so I will be just
saying a few words based on this rather
than all the other things that are
answered in other places
um can I just uh say to start with
though that um we don't have the uh the
enormous Reliance just on tourism that
we did there's been a lot of work done
um working to
attract other industry and if you look
at that uh the the table eight on page
39 and look at the mixture of employment
I think that tells you a lot that
manufacturing is
17.32 percent
and I just
I just throw that in because you know
sometimes the spurious oh we only rely
on Shakespeare
is thrown out all the time
would be Bonkers not to rely a lot on
Shakespeare because we've got such a an
attraction to get people to come into
this District
um I also wanted to pick up I was like
my nose is slightly out of joint talking
about women who work from home running
their businesses I felt a bit matronized
on that one because that's exactly what
I've done but I don't just run it from
the kitchen table and it's not just a
micro business
um there are plenty of us who are
of my gender capable of running really
quite competent concerns and I just
raised that because
all is not so difficult necessarily
about being a woman and being in
business
um that some of the figures that we've
got here will represent the fact that
women make choices women often have to
make choices
and possibly more than men these at the
moment
but that is something for them and it's
not really for something for us I think
to be frankly quite so opinionated about
um and then on housing um we apparently
haven't got social housing well the
reason we've got social housing is
because the opposition party flogged it
all in 1995 there were reasons that they
had to but that's why
I as the housing portfolio holder
desperately wants to build more because
I understand that we really really need
and I say this to you Jason and I've
said it quite a few times
I passionately believe in proper
affordable social housing 30 seconds and
that is certainly something that we are
working towards
finally on infrastructure
um I don't know how many of you are
aware but I had a conversation with the
I was lucky enough the chief executive
of seven Trent this uh last week and
they aren't actually statutory
consulties on sewage and water so we are
pushing water
somewhat uphill on that one oh very good
forgive me
um because but but never fear I am
lobbying in other places for that piece
of legislation to be changed thank you
very much councilman
Cassie kettle
and having average earnings above the
West Midlands and Great Britain average
um percentage of qualified people above
West Midlands and Great Britain average
uh having more High proportional
manufacturing than Great Britain and
West Midlands
um
and employment
the same would you agree with me that
those are signs of success in this
District
yes of course we need to support those
who are less well-off we need to improve
our housing as does every other district
and Authority in this country
but we are building as there is an
answer to a later question more
affordable housing than any other
neighboring District
is that not a sign that we're doing
something right I would think it is
going on to the final point that was
made earlier
about the preponderance of Tourism and
clearly
um tourism is very important but I was
supposed to divide resources away from
tourism I always thought are we trying
to or should we be concentrating not on
um
developing an exploiting one of the
world's greatest tourism assets William
Shakespeare should we ignore that should
we Chuck it away because we've got more
tourists than other districts perhaps Mr
chair visit the leader you might
consider whether that's a sense of
policy or whether we should continue to
focus where we can on our greatest asset
that we have
thank you Council Council Fielding
no one what I've come across in the my
six years of working in this
organization is the fact that there are
government
prevention such as Greenfield which
prevents the change of use of old
agricultural buildings where they could
be used for social housing to encourage
social housing in The Villages it's a
very important part of what we're doing
also I've come up a road come against
the roadblock which is within the
conservation area you are again
restricted to try and build that sort of
property
the other matter to do is write
um tourism is that I have been an
advocate of trying to upgrade our rights
away uh Bridal powers for the Leisure
industry for
um people who want to go Pony trekking
which would then encourage stables and
other things within the area I think we
ought to be a little bit more proactive
but most of all Lobby the government to
take away this so-called Greenfield
matter that's a thorn in any planning
planners applicant's side when he's
trying to get some housing on to what
was old agricultural land
thank you Council Harvey and then
Council Pemberton I'm wrapping it up
thank you
um
I really wanted to endorse the leaders
comments in thanking Mr perfield and his
staff for producing this paper the
debate has been very interesting in that
various councils have raised various
aspects and they've asked for more
detailed information we could equally
have a debate about housing about
employment about women there are
numerous areas in which we could seek
for further information and I do notice
that we've got a paper here which skims
over the surface
lifts a lot of Lids potentially and yet
produces 40 pages which apparently some
counselors can't quite manage to read at
all
um
a paper which would uh would have
addressed all of the answers to all of
the questions on all of the issues which
have been raised this afternoon
um May well have been the length of War
and Peace I don't think we want papers
that long but I do think we've created
an agenda of items where we we do need
some additional information in order
that we can have an intelligent informed
and useful debate thank you Mr chair
thank you thank you right finally uh
Council Pemberton
um thank you very much chairman um
the leader on more than one occasion
talked about the being uh no money and
that's not an original quote as I recall
um
but the one thing that members should
absolutely understand that that is said
with no joy with no Glee
um it's said with a heavy heart
it
on a lighter vein the phrase that
strikes fear into my heart with my
almost daily conversations with the
leader is when the leader starts with
I've been reading The Economist
um and that's because we're not in a
great place economically as a country as
a planet
um but because
um the leader talks about there being no
money be Lefty no doubt whatsoever that
does not diminish the ambition of this
Council to do the right thing and to do
the right thing well to ensure that our
residents lives are improved
because what actually happens is this
slot ran these two rows here the cabinet
in conjunction with the senior officers
are spending all their time trying to
find smart and innovative ways to get
get around all this and find ways to
find a penny here or a pound there or a
way of partnering with somebody so that
they can
um so that we can deliver services so I
just wanted to start with that to say
it's realistic it's just being honest
with you trying to be adult with you but
it by no means means that we're given up
on this thing so just to be clear on
that
um
the state of the district is a snapshot
it's a reflective piece it brings in
what residents think through the survey
it's not meant to be the whole detail
um
uh of our economic strategy and members
will be aware that this question was was
this bridge was crossed some years ago
about an understanding about widening
our economic offering and members will
be aware of of the economic strategy
that's been going to be consulted on so
members will have an opportunity to
ensure that as we move forward we have a
strategy that is as wide as our
aspirations are and similarly when we
talk about housing
and councilor forward check you and I
are on the same page and with councilor
Barker if there was some way of being
able to like that build more houses do
it in a heartbeat Birmingham thinks
they're great at achieving 11 affordable
so just let's remember we're reasonably
we are reasonably good at affordable
housing within the constraints we have
not owning our own stock but again
housing is around the housing plan that
the South Warwickshire local plan so
whilst members may feel there's not
enough detail within the district state
report remember it's a snapshot and
there are other pieces of work where you
and councilor rocks involved in the
local plan work you're all involved in
different things and there will be those
opportunities to come forward and
discuss those in detail so just because
the district report doesn't cover the to
the end degree detail about that do not
for a second think that's not being
covered and I would Inc courage and and
hope that all members engage with the
various strategies that this Authority
has to put together to take us forward
thank you
well thank you very much indeed Council
Pemberton right I'm going to call on the
leader to sum up and appreciating this
has gone on for quite a quite a decent
time a summary and then any of those
questions we will take out and then send
a a an email to all the counselors on
the questions have been raised thank you
cancer
thank you chair
yes an interesting debate
I mean obviously there are an awful lot
of issues around not all of which I
would say are capable of being sold
easily or quickly
I would take issue with wealth councilor
junip said I don't think I've been
disingenuous at all
uh there is no doubt about it covered in
the cost of living crisis have hit hard
and destabilized things
uh
Council adjunate also said it will take
some years to fix
actually it will
there is no doubt about it that the
reality is we need a strategy for the
medium and long term
and with cabinet colleagues we are
working on that with an economic
strategy we are working on that to put
the local plan together
and I would say that getting a local
plan is really important when it comes
to looking at the issues on housing that
many people have actually raised
uh it will be very significant
so I take on board the points that
councilor Wally hoggins and councilor
fragile have made about females and
female counselors
um
when we actually look at the age and
population as some people mentioned it
will cause pressures it will do that
across the country because the national
population is aging
the issue councilor put together raised
about infrastructure
absolutely right the one thing that we
have tried to push time and time again
when we come to local planning and
looking forward in the local plan is the
absolute and of the significance of
infrastructure
my own personal view is that we have
done too much Building without the
infrastructure in place
I think councilor barkers raised the
issue about dealing with seven Trent and
how she's been lobbying 7 Trent because
there are issues on water supply there
are issues on waste and sewage and I
know councilor Bromwich is written to be
on the topic and I believe that
councilor Rock has done the same
these are really big issues and they
will need to be tackled and believe me
we are lobbying for them to be tackled
okay
uh one thing I would say is an awful lot
of the issues that need to tackling our
complex
they are not going to be easy and
they're not going to be short-term I
agree with everything that councilor
Kettle said
the points are we really do need to be
realistic we need to remember with a
successful District
however we will continue to strive to be
better
and we are ambitious be under no doubt
whatsoever about that we want to do the
best for the district and for our
residents thank you thank you very much
indeed and I'd just like to Echo what
has been said a couple of times now
um it is a snapshot but it's a very good
report and I'd like to thank Simon and
his team for producing it
good
not an easy task not an easy task right
thank you very much indeed the
recommendation members for you is that
the state of the Stratford debonne
Stratford on Avon district is noted and
the issues raised are considered as part
of the budget making process for 23 24.
do I have agreement on that
thank you very much indeed members I am
going to take a five minute break
I know
um
cushion to this place
the compromise
um
come on guys
come on guys
can we start moving back please thank
you
well he's late
okay look don't worry about it like so I
fully understand just put your hand up
if you want to and I'll just saying
I think you might go together then okay
then yeah no problem
is
yeah no problem
yeah no problem
come on please thank you members come on
I want to go home today
I want to go home today
about my five minutes
well I've lost Mr Buckland
that's because oh he's already stepped
out fine right in that case then thank
you very much indeed item seven on the
agenda appointment of the returning
officer electoral registration officer
and Deputy returning officer it's not
funny
and Deputy Electrical uh registration
officer councilor Jefferson would you
like to introduce this report please
I would indeed this is should be very
straightforward the recommendations are
clear on page 65 uh recommendation one
that David Dolby interim electoral
services manager be appointed as
returning officer and electoral
registration officer with effect from
the 17th of October 2022 and the mesha
Nash Democratic services manager be
appointed as Deputy returning officer
and Deputy electoral registration
officer with the veteran 17th of October
can I have a second to please
first uh Casa Junaid I I was hoping to
second right
I would like
both of them
doing the work for the council
thank you I agree thank you very much
indeed uh all those in favor yes thank
you
thank you very much indeed right the
next item uh updates on the Constitution
uh I'd like Mr Grafton just to uh add a
few comments first before we enter into
this one
yeah just prior to the leader um
introducing the item
um the two two things I want to draw
attention to the first one is on page
80.
it's
um just above halfway down the page
Point number five for head of Housing
and customer services to write off
amounts due from an individual account
under council tax or nndr legislation to
a maximum five five thousand pounds that
delegation is new it wasn't as a direct
result of the management team
restructure but I also want to point out
that that is an extra one and the other
one that I want to point out is on page
91.
and bearing in mind the decision you've
just taken under
item seven on the agenda
uh the second paragraph
on page 91 Begins the Democratic
services manager Etc of course that
should Now read the the interim
electoral services manager is appointed
as delete Deputy returning officer and
delete Deputy electoral registration
officer Etc so I just wanted to point
out those two amendments now let the
leader introduce the report thank you
[Music]
thank you in essence this paper is a
tidying up exercise
it's to reflect the management
restructure that's happened and it also
deletes the joint in terms of
appointments being joined with Warwick
district and Stratford on island
District the reality is as I said that
is a tidying up exercise if there are
any specific questions I'm sure Mr
Grafton will be happy to answer them
thank you thank you very much indeed I'm
a proposal can I have a second for this
please casa shenton
thank you very much indeed uh do any
members wish to say anything well in
that case then
um Phil would you like to confirm it's
only a slight change to the
recommendation that the changes to the
council's Constitution as detailed in
the amended appendices that I've just
referred to
Etc thank you all those in favor
thank you
the next item is item nine uh proposed
change of the planning delegations I'd
like Council
oh shall we let them in
oh I suppose so yeah okay then let them
in
you are back in
you see no uh there's no one else
I thought I thought there were more than
that it's okay all right okay
right members item nine you do have
before you're in appendix I'm going to
ask councilor Richards to introduce this
please
councils uh have the opportunity for
asking delegations to uh trigger
planning applications to come to
committee and indeed represent
themselves that committee uh that same
opportunity hasn't been afforded to uh
to Parish meetings
um whilst discretion has been provided
to allow for Parish meetings to bring
items to and to speak at um at
committees which indeed happened just
two weeks ago
um this is seeking to tighten up our
constitution uh to formalize their
inclusion to be able to to make that
trigger and to represent themselves
um you will also have received an email
from me this morning and hopefully you
all have a nice yellow piece of paper on
your desk
um I'm afraid that isn't a further
amendment to what has been put in front
of you
um sadly I missed the deadline for
getting this in before the papers were
printed so I apologize for that
um again you'll have seen this morning
uh my my reasoning for this in essence
the uh the proposed amendment that I'm
making is to seek Town councils parish
councils and Parish meeting applications
when they're made on behalf of
themselves or on their behalf will be
brought to committee for a decision to
be made now I've added in some wording
to say where the officer's
recommendation is for refusal let me
give you a bit of background so you can
understand why that is I'm hugely
indebted to John Kevin and his team for
providing me with this information
apparently it was very difficult to come
by so a huge thanks to him and his team
for getting this for me I can tell you
in the last five years we've had 95
applications made by either a town or
Parish Council or Paris meeting
um of which the vast majority are for
trimming trees
um 20 of those applications the last
five years have been for either a full
outline or an LBC application so it's a
very small amount the purpose of
including that refusal is to ensure that
we don't have every item that comes to
us when it's a straightforward uh tree
operation it is to bring those forwards
that need to be open transparent so
ultimately this is an opening open and
transparency thing as far as I can I'm
concerned I don't think it's
controversial I hope it's not but if I
could please propose the amendment uh
sorry the full change and the amendment
as uh as it's worded on the piece of
yellow paper in front of you that would
be great and I will say for secondary
thank you
um first of all may I have a second for
this
counter Jennings
thank you right um now there's a number
of people put the hands up uh first at
councilor Rock
but um
I basically I I I support this uh both
elements of this because both both
elements I believe give transparency to
uh what we're trying to do and uh those
of us that have got royal Awards with a
lot of small communities that are
don't meet the climate repairs Council
on our Parish meetings instead I think
we should allow on the same Democratic
input as everybody else and I think that
was the original intent anyway so I have
no problem with it and I'm pleased to
support you thank you chair thank you
very much councilor Donna
because as someone who has a number of
Parish meetings within their rural award
it is refreshing to see and also a
relief when I was campaigning in Camden
Vale early in the year sadly there the
liberal Democrats were actually
introducing an initiative to try and
remove both parish councils and Parish
meetings from the planning
um process so I'm relieved to see that
we are maintaining openness and
transparentness and I'm also relief to
see that over here our friends are not
doing the same but that is a fact if you
look at the literature from that last
that by-election that was there so thank
you for bringing this over
thank you Council Perry did you want to
speak
second The Proposal which I'm totally in
favor of and would like to thank
councilor Richard zazar excellent chair
of the planning committee for bringing
it forward thank you Council Richard
thank you councilor kettle
D clarification explains so parishes
understand why they have 10 working days
for uh planning in principal
applications where 15 days for other
applications
um I I don't believe that is a change
um I think that has always been the case
I I am going to have to defer to our
monitoring officer just for his
confirmation but I believe that has been
the case all the way through we haven't
changed that
thank you okay members
um we have a proposal of a second the
recommendation is that the proposed
changes are set out in the amended
appendix to the report be approved and
that the monitoring office will be
authorized to amend the Constitution
accordingly all those in favor
thank you passed
right next item item uh
10 minutes of motion Freedom of
Information request
um I would invite councilor Jefferson
leader of the council to introduce this
report
thank you chair
a very simple and straightforward report
I would draw your attention to the
second paragraph comment was informed
what a district council did not usually
publish its responses online this was a
one-off publication in regards to the
merger there's no legal requirement for
local authorities to publish Freedom of
Information or environment environmental
information regulation responses I would
say a cabinet concluded that this would
mean if we were to publish all of them
it would mean extra work probably extra
costs and it would add little value so
we rejected the notice of motion and
what I am recommending to council that
the notice of motion be rejected thank
you do I have a second here for that
Council Barker thank you very much
indeed councilor Junaid
with regret that uh I I note this uh I I
accept you know that if that is the case
that it will cost more money and and I
certainly do not want to
um be responsible for costing the
council any more money
see I firmly believe that if we can be
efficient and transparent at the same
time to the maximum than it is to the
benefit of any Council under the benefit
of residents so it is with that in mind
that I moved it originally uh please
bear in mind that the more you keep
residents informed the better it is so
whether you accept this or reject this I
think the the uh please take on board
that can residents do want to be kept
informed thank you thank you very much
Council Junaid
anyone else counselor yes by all means
thank you Mr chairman yep um as the next
officer of a district council Freedom of
Information requests
could often be quite challenging and
time consuming uh having read the report
and it came to audience standards as
well one and a half full-time equivalent
staff to-do list potentially where staff
were struggling to recruit staff we're
struggling to resign staff retain staff
apologists
so therefore let's spend our money
wisely we can be transparent we can be
accountable and I think if members do
have an issue which well they're not
getting the information or their
residents are not getting information
Freedom of Information requests are not
the way to do it we often see agencies
using the Freedom of Information
requests to get information to save
themselves money doing it a different
way uh so we publish a heck of a lot of
information on our website we are
transparent and personally I think we
need to spend our money wisely and
somebody said in this meeting today
there's no money was that right
thank you thank you Council Crump it
sounds like an echo
are there any other members we should
speak right uh the notion of the the
item before is sorry thank you very much
indeed uh to reject the notice of motion
uh all those in favor
thank you
please keep your hands up
now against
it
all those against
abstain oh sorry I can't support Jake
and Council prepared together and
abstentions
thank you very much indeed Gary
right
the next item then is the minute 267
development requirements
supplementary planning document you
thought you of the section 106 planning
obligations councilor Jefferson
councilor Pemberton then
as members will be aware there is an
ongoing process of developing
supplementary planning documents to
support the existing core strategy the
item before you as as Council
um it's a canceled decision around the
adoption of spds
the uh there are two parts to this part
U which relates to planning operations
under section 106 and then part L which
relates to open spaces and the
recommendation before you is that
amendments depart you as they relate to
section 106 obligations are approved and
that the proposed amendments to part L
as they relate to open space policy
development requirements uh be formally
consulted upon I I seek a seconder for
that and uh hopefully that will be
something that we can move to or I'll
take questions so I'm happy to second
because um it was in 2019 that some
residents came to this Council and spoke
in public about the problems that they
were having in getting public space
adopted I've come across several other
similar cases more recently and those
those residents have grouped together
with other residents from not only this
area but also across the country the
only thing that um that is not being
addressed here is a retrospective
Provisions but I don't think that's that
is not within our capacity that is a
government thing to do but what we could
do we can do and that is to make sure
that we do not get the situation where
private companies managing land put the
prices up year on year on year and don't
properly maintain it to the standard
that we as a district council and our
town and Parish councils always have
done and would do and I do appreciate
that this is a a step forward in the
right direction thank you very much
Council Pemberton did you want to thank
you councilor Junior just to confirm
much to everybody in this room's regret
there is nothing that we can do
retrospectively about public open space
and
um uh the way that it is managed by
private companies uh in my own Ward I've
I had an example of a Housing
Development that chose not to engage
with the parish council and went down
the roots of a managed company approach
and I think we've all decided in this
room and that's what we're going to give
life to in this policy uh that that's
not where we're going
um open space should be managed by tan
or Parish councils or by some uh
residence group it shouldn't be managed
and seen as a revenue stream uh for for
private companies so uh with that I'm
hoping that members will be supportive
of the two recommendations thank you
thank you very much uh right the members
are we all in agreement on this
great thank you that is carried thank
you very much indeed the next item item
12 is minute 301 Community governance
review great Walford and little Walford
councilorly Hawkins
okay I should explain there is a night
another appendix with this one so
if I made the next three items you
should have three pieces of white paper
on your desks Council Wally hoggins will
talk to the audit and standards
committee item which is item 12. there's
one then unemployment subcommittee item
13 and the independent person's
recruitment subcommittee agenda item 14.
so we're talking to the loose papers and
of course then you have questions on the
green paper later thank you sorry carry
on thank you it's like it is my
privilege to be the ward member for
great Wilford and little Walford I
recommend this to the council as it is
an excellent example of putting
residents at the heart of the
decision-making process in the Stratford
District this is because this is what
the residents of both great Wilford and
little Wolford want
so if you look through the minute 301
little Wilford is a is a really a hamlet
there's a there's a handful of
properties there and it has become
increasingly difficult for them to find
residents able to undertake
um what is you know the legally binding
um
uh requirements of of conducting Parish
meetings and so therefore they proposed
to amalgamate with great Wilford and
great Wilford parish is welcoming them
with open arms and I and I think that I
have to pay respect to both the
residents of little Walford for being
sensible as to the limitations of the
size of their Village and I must also
pay respect to the parish councilors and
the residents of great Wilford uh for
saying that this is the right way and
literally for extending that hand of
friendship that we've come to know and
regard across the Stratford District
thank you thank you Council uh do I have
a second for this Council Pemberton are
there any other members would like to
speak on this
no thank you right the recommendation to
council is that the community governance
review for great Warford and little
Walford commence in accordance with the
terms of reference and appendix one to
the agenda report and that a report be
made to Council on the 12th of December
2022 with the final recommendations all
in the favor
thank you very much indeed
moving on to the next item item 13.
sorry this is where we say au revoir to
Mr Burrell
thank you very much indeed item 13 is
the employment subcommittee and
councilor Jefferson
thank you chair this again should be
exceeding straightforward uh the
employment subcommittee interviewed for
the appointment of head of resources in
sections 151 officer and we resolved
that Richard Burrell be appointed so can
I recommend to council that Richard Burr
will be appointed section 1051 officer
to commence today
cancer unit
and also to welcome him to the uh to the
position thank you thank you very much
indeed any other members Mr Speaker
in which case I will go to the
recommendation that Richard Burrell be
appointed section 151 officer to
commence Monday the 17th of October 2022
and I wish him well in this new position
all those in favor
thank you you can let him back in now
and thank you
and uh
foreign
congratulations Richard
[Applause]
right uh item 14 again there's a report
item in front of you
um Council of fitter
consists of members councilors uh Paulie
hoggins foot check and put together we
also had Parish counselor Kim James and
the independent person Mike Dutton so
following the interviews the
subcommittee recommends that Edward
McAllister Smith to the role of the
independent person well the committee
also asked that the future audience
standards Community looks to review the
uh the allowance for the independent
person thank you
thank you uh do I have a second for this
Casper together thank you very much
indeed uh anyone else wish to speak on
this subject
the recommendation to council then is
that subject to the receipt of
satisfactory references Edward
McAllister Smith the appointed to the
vision of the position of independent
person pursue into section 28 of the
localism ACT 2011 for a four-year term
commencing on 17th of October 2022
subject to any extension that may be
agreed arising from the needs of this
okay it's a long one of the service
including the induction and training
needs of a newly appointed persons in
the role all those in favor
thank you very much indeed members
Right Moving rapidly on
we have councilor questions correct me
if I'm wrong
a Green Sheet yes I have you have the
Green Sheet in front of you thank you
very much indeed
right I've been a number of questions
asked and thank you very much indeed for
those Council of pojeck do you have a
supplementary question
yes
watching for the answers of just one
supplementary question for for both
questions actually so
um it's it's the information that you
provide that's been provided it doesn't
break down social and affordable but
also particularly unaffordable the
affordable to rent and affordable to buy
that's that information I don't have and
I think it would be very interesting to
know what that would be because
um three weeks ago on Home Choice plus
64 properties were available however 61
of those were shared ownership only
requiring purchase of over a hundred
thousand pounds so
it can be quite misleading when we've
got figures here that actually say
something there's another story behind
it sometimes but thank you for the
answer I received Council Barker can I
disagree yes there is another story
behind it
um and uh it's not always a story I'm
that happy about either as you're aware
um particularly when it comes to the
part by part rent type of ownership
which I think can be very very difficult
for people and we've all got residents
who've tried to extract themselves from
such arrangements and it hasn't always
proved easy it would be much easier if
the whole situation was a lot simpler we
are looking
at doing everything we can to simplify
Home Choice plus and to make it much
more transparent because frankly I don't
understand it half the time either
you had a second question do you do you
have a supplementary to that no thank
you very much you do moving on Council
Bromwich you'll have your response do
you have a supplementary question
third round I was part of my question
when I asked whether the vehicles were
leased or purchased says regardless of
vehicles at least or purchased portfolio
holder there is a difference between a
vehicle being purchased the vehicle
being leased in any contract
one would mean that we'd have an asset
the other means we don't so I think do
you accept that that is probably should
not be regardless that actually the
better word it would have been that so
just explain why the Vex had been leased
or been purchased then we could have
tackled that issue so first of all I'd
like a clarification on that
the next question thanks one at a time
thank you yep thanks for playing
the uh the Spade work was done on this
work so that there were you know the
officers spent a lot of time comparing
the residual values and whatever else so
so from that perspective
they work to get the best deal for the
council the best residual at the end of
the contracts because you know an
eight-year-old to a refuge collection
vehicle doesn't have a great deal of
value so having looked at uh
purchasing upfront or even over a period
it still was the best economical value
to go for a lease vehicle so
does it say regardless it does say
regardless but but what happened was the
officers went for the best deal for the
council over the eight-year period so
that's that's what was done
thank you Council for me uh right
Council Bryce your next question
um item for question four do you have
the supplementary question for that
right then so yeah so obviously this
part of the reason for submitting this
question here regardless Audi
application and regarding highways it's
because the original application has
been in over a year
and we the poor planning officers had a
letter one point which stated that the
officer involved at the County Council
highways was actually a way of maternity
leave which delayed this application
then when they finally decided the
problem for the application that has
been submitted which is in relation to
this again
the question has to be do we think that
we have to be a bit more forthcoming at
times towards watch a County Council
highways especially if they there were
delays to planning applications
course by them which really could have
been dealt with a lot sooner rather than
poor officers sitting there waiting in
this example over a year now to try and
get something resolved
thank you
um yes
I think um cancer Bromwich for this I
take your point I I do take your point
um but
um there is regular meetings obviously
with highways and with County on on lots
of different matters
I'll take it back as I sit on the
regulatory committee at County I will
take that point back to them but uh I I
don't think there's any more that I can
say about it okay
thank you
um Council junent on question six do you
have any supplementary question
you're at all
structure District Council will be
applying for this particular rural fund
could you make it clearer whether or not
you will be applying for that fund
did you want to respond
thank you apologies if if it wasn't
clear
um as with
every funding opportunity yes
thank you right question seven uh
councilor Adam do you have a
supplementary
holder um I am disappointed that we're
not able to get more of a breakdown in
terms of the uh the service that we've
received I don't want to protract this
um because I know it's a good service
for a lot of our residents but you know
over the weekend I'm still getting
messages of people who are having missed
bin collections yeah we're now in
October
um so I do I would like to know why
we're not being able to get a breakdown
at least by Depot because there are now
two Depots that we're using for it
um uh and you know and it is a very
localized area that is being affected
specifically around southam so I would
like that and I'd also like to know what
penalties are being applied to biffer
because you know we've been briefed on
this and the penalties do get applied I
think it was after the first of
September and yet without without more
detailed breakdown I don't see how we
can get that information so could I have
a bit more uh elaboration on on the
response please thank you all right
Council Fleming did you want to respond
on that
yeah I've been getting a lot of these
questions over osc and and at other
meetings
um
the trend is that things are getting
better
yeah I mean I've got some figures that
I've just recently got recently and
the point is we are making improvements
there's a couple of hot spots that are
still still difficult and they seem to
be in the same place which unfortunately
for the same people is a big problem but
it's been actively worked on by the
officers and with um meetings regularly
with biffer
um penalties are being considered and
negotiated but the print the problem
with penalties and whatever is when the
initial contracts are set up the more
you add in penalties the more the
contract becomes becomes unaffordable so
these things have been reached as an
agreement after a period of time we're
now working through that and believe me
these penalties will be applied
with Force by the by the officers so
um we're not letting anybody offer this
scot-free
um and uh these things have been worked
on as we speak thank you thank you
councilman on your next question do you
have a supplementary
um
to the portfolio holder for the response
um
I would like to know again just a bit
more detail in which agencies we're
working with because obviously this is
incredibly pressing for a number of
residents uh I am aware of the support
that's coming from County and that's
appreciated but I'd like to know if
there's something we can do more than
just disseminate information on the
support other councils are doing uh
actually what we can do with our assets
and our abilities throughout the
district
thank you thank you
right the next item Council Bertie
Geller
that's right sorry did you wish to
respond to that I apologize moving on
sorry about that thank you
um uh interestingly I just had something
through from National Grid there's
another funding source so if you are
tapping into wrcc sources of funding
that's now the National Grid as well
um we certainly are working quite hard
to support action across the uh District
whether it's in buildings that we have
access to
um Mr klatz and I have been discussing
what we can do here but also using the
um
Cloud Council offices potentially if
they're available and other
hubs so for instance in shipston I know
I've had three offers of places that
make suitable hubs
one of which will be the model that we
have open all the not all the time at
all
throughout the day others are specific
times which is a bit more like the
bidford model where they open at
specific times with advice and soup and
that kind of thing so a lot of work
going on in the background and anybody
who wants to talk to me about it or Mr
blutz please do well probably me
actually
um please do so but I think it's it's a
really really good Grassroots thing that
we're a lot of us involved in it doesn't
take much space
um and we've got lots of blankets in
Shepstone because everybody knits so
should you require more knitting just
ask
well bear that in mind thank you
right now Council pedigality you have a
supplementary question
I'm disappointed that resources
implications will prevent the production
of such an important list for a Harrier
so in the meantime will the portfolio
order commit to provide the Worcester
County Council environment historic
environment record on the council's
website so that residents the world
members Parish councils Parish meetings
and can access these records in all
planning matters
because of Hamilton
thank you
um it doesn't fall within my portfolio
however I'm sure that John careford is
uh watching this uh intently and no
doubt will liaise with his I.T
colleagues to put an appropriate link on
the appropriate page of the website and
to signpost it so that that information
can be accessible online
thank you question 11 is counter Jenny
frankly
do you have a supplementary
thank you question Charles counselor in
front of me do you have a supplementary
yesterday I made sure
um
my recollection is that it was
originally planned that key workers were
to be the main occupancy of this
building so the current mix is rather
disappointing please could I ask
councilor Barker if you could arrange to
email me a copy of the section 106
agreement
thank you councilman would you like to
respond
thank you
right count to 13. uh question 30 not
Council 13. you're much more at the top
of the list than that I can tell you
Jill
[Laughter]
would you like to uh ask a supplementary
question yeah thank you and lucky for
some I suppose
um thanks thank you councilor Fleming
for um but my question was regarding the
reported part of the app overall not
just miss bins I've had residents use it
to report other issues include including
an overflowing Street litter bin but
they don't seem to get any confirmation
uh when the reports when they've sent
the report so
um and it I've been notified that it
still resulted in me having to contact
Street Scene so we're just wondering
what actually happens to all of the
different reports whether it's uh dead
animals the abandoned abandoned vehicles
those sort of things
how often how soon do they get notified
um the relevant partners and is there
any data data available on the use of
the app thank you
um using my jail card I obviously
haven't been here long enough to find
out all the answers to that
um so what I will do is I'll make sure
that I take that back to uh to the
officers that I work with and I'll get
back to you with the answers okay
thank you councilor orcock do you have a
supplementary
[Music]
question in um it hadn't hit the Press
so
um but obviously great minds think alike
um can I request please counselor Barca
that as the position of this Council
working with these Charities additional
organizations including the Fred winter
Center that as a district we have we
have supported financially as well as
with volunteer Etc that we just have a
review of the entire system to ensure it
is working as we expected it to and also
so we can
get a grip on what I think is going to
what I consider is going to be a problem
that gets a lot worse before it starts
getting better just to ensure that we
are at top of our game
please it's certainly um something that
because I sit on the Strategic board and
that we have talked about we will talk
about again and I will bring a report
back to you
um with hopefully some nice positive
things to say
thank you
uh Council Junior do you have a secular
supplementary
it is a supplementary because
I'm the answer rather unhelpful
um the the the Duty Officers are
certainly on one occasion that um of the
complaint that was made to me did not
Point them in the direction of the
planning portal
um so it would be you know how all I was
asking for was could a simple link be
made on the website to the planning
portal so that people actually knew
without having to go through to the duty
officer that they could find out for
themselves
it you know the on both of these
occasions people were asked for the full
elevations the full site plan the sill
form and the fee of 103 could you please
make this simpler and clearer for um for
applicants please
Council shamed him
answered unit
um I think the answer is is actually
fairly full if you write specific
instances I would say bring them to me
and I'll have a look at the specific
incidences but
um
I think the answer the answer says it
all um
two there's two instances you've got and
I don't hear widespread concerns over it
it has to be cost benefit look at that
but if you give me the individual
instances you'll certainly take them
away and have a look at them
thank you councilor Rolf do you have a
supplementary question
so you thought these will be fair
ly selected after a bus robust call for
projects so uh could you tell me who is
going to select and assess
um and also will there be local input
from
um
from the from the residents and other
parties
um or is it just going to be a cabinet
decision thank you
because of Hamilton thank you thank you
chairman thank you councilor Rolf
um I envisaged that it'll run in a very
similar way to how civil funding works
so that the the sifting assessment will
be by the officers and then that will
bring forward recommendations
um to Cabinet uh and I would expect that
in in the same way that uh sill is
concerned there is there is local input
and certainly as Ward members that you'd
have input around
um supporting particular projects
thank you uh councilor Jenny franchi you
have a supplementary no thank you and
finally correct me if I'm wrong
no I'm wrong
I must turn over the page cancel
um with the state of the district data
telling us that we have had an increase
in an elderly population does their
portfolio disagree that in inpatient
beds in our community hospitals must be
provided for preventative palliative and
emergency care
cancer Market
as we've uh told you told you in the
answer the um bed review still hasn't
been published and I I'm not expecting
to see it now until January as a member
of Swift
um the reason being that as you may have
gathered you were at the meeting there's
been a lot of touring and throwing on
this subject
and as a result
um the there's more work being done and
that's all I can say at the moment on
the Ellen Badger and on the nickel unit
and on any other bits of local Community
Hospitals but do not forget that in
South Warwickshire we're quite close
arbit of South Warwickshire we're quite
close to gloucestershire so we do have
the Morton Community Hospital available
as well which I took my broken legged
son to the other day
thank you Council bucket right councilor
cleave
you're not 19 incidentally
right 19 yes
um yeah
thank you I know we do attempt to
provide our residents with the right
information at the right time but I was
just wondering as as we have an amazing
it team who I assume do look after our
website uh could we possibly look at
having a dedicated page on our website
um similar to the one that Warwick
Warwick Council have so that we can
direct our residents to that page I can
stop referring to theirs personally
thanks
part of me would like to say yes the the
other part of me I'd like to say
do we really need to be told uh I'm just
going to leave it like that I haven't
put my heating on yet
um it's how much advice do people
actually need we've got act on energy
we've got all the advice like that that
you know the serious stuff and I think
that's what they need but most people do
know what they're doing
oh we put it up well great so
scrap that if there's one up okay
thanks guys
thank you Council Parker right final
question councilor O'Donnell do you have
a supplementary
planning for your response I'm afraid it
leaves me with more questions
so I just felt the overall response
really lacks compassion in its approach
for our most vulnerable residents the
elderly and the disabled and I'd urge
you when you are considering this a
cabinet to perhaps look to the
commissioner for human rights with the
mindset to be taking this situation into
account for
the problem with the need for an extra
collection is due to the reduced
frequency of the gray bin collection
that's what made residents come to me
with these concerns
um also I must clarify Catherine John do
you have a question for the Paul Bearer
I do I've got this it goes into three as
the other peoples did and I will I will
actually just fulfill the points
um you've said that the waste I'm
referring to is not clinical waste
according to the NHS any waste which
consists wholly or partly of human
tissue blood or other body fluids
excretions drugs or other pharmaceutical
products is clinical waste and that's
what I've come to about the question so
I'd ask you to come back to me with that
one the other question the other part
then to the question you come back on
which I'm quite frankly flabbergasted
about
is you state that one of the reasons for
introducing the new one two three plus
waste scheme was to encourage all
residents to think more about how they
dispose of their waste by Recycling and
this applies equally to the elderly and
vulnerable residents how can they think
differently about clinical and
incontinence waves they don't have a
choice
so I'd ask perhaps councilor Mills give
me a good um suggestion he says why
can't clinical and human waste be
collected free of charge or more
regularly and also councilor Rock and I
have examples of other authorities where
this works so I know this is the first
draft but I'd urge you to come back with
more compassion and insight into the
choices these residents having to make
every single day so they can have the
care within their home and just with
life limiting conditions sometimes have
a good quality of life
foreign
yes
um I'll come back to you on that I mean
obviously I take uh instruction from the
offices that I work with and and and and
the fact that
sorry
um thank you councilor Rock
um
I take information then from the offices
that I work with and uh and this is the
information that they fed back to me now
we can do any of these things any of
them but they're carrying a cost burden
and I'll Echo the guy behind me there is
no money
um
in in at first pass we're looking at
between 200 and 250 000 pounds to make
this work now we need to find out where
that's going to come from you know so
from that perspective I'll go back I'll
discuss with the officers again and I'll
come back to you with another answer
that might be the same answer but I know
the answer okay thank you thank you very
much indeed
okay members let's move on item 16
questions to the members I'd like to
remind members
to the leader
sorry
to the two questions per member maximum
and three minutes total
for each counselor and only matters at
the responsibility of this Council and
we have up to 30 minutes so can I move
on account said Rolf was first
oh Council in frantially
Council for Jack I think Council
together okay okay all right Victoria we
got you there in Castle Rock
and cancer Cleve
right I think that might just do us
completely so let's move on oh I think
councilor Pemberton would like one as
well
right thank you very much let's move on
thank you very much Council building all
right
and Council Bromwich okay that's it
okay all right thank you Council Rob and
we are timing now 30 minutes
oh no my question isn't going to take 30
minutes I know it won't take you that
long councilor off
well you did say 30 minutes uh so I
asked councilor Fleming at ons
um this question and his answer was he
hadn't responded may I ask you as leader
have you received the letter from the
watch your Wildlife trust and have you
responded to it
I have received it I have read it I
haven't responded as yet
I tend to respond to it
yes
right Council in freshly
thank you chair I have two questions do
I ask them at the same time or
yeah bye bye thank you
um
my first question to try and get a view
of the way Bridgetown residents have
reacted to putting out their bins in the
new bin collection system I've been
doing a bin day walk in my ward over the
last seven weeks something to do at 6 30
a.m in the morning
um
uh and what I've what I've identified
over these seven weeks is 87 put out
their blue bins on Blue been connection
days
84 put out their black bins on black bin
collection days
77 put out their green bins on green bin
collection days
just 54 put out their caddies every
collection day but this is this was
reduced to 51 when it was a caddy only
day which suggests that it is more than
likely that residents put their caddies
out
when there is another bin or more going
out at the same time
my question is please could you tell me
how well these figures are the norm
across the district and are there any
notable differences in where the bins
are put out or otherwise on for
different days of the week for instance
my
is that your first question
that's quite a detailed one
that's a question no I think we'll just
let counselor Jefferson want you to
respond to that
uh I have to say councilor frankly there
is not a chance to be responding to a
question of that detail in this meeting
I will see if the information is
available and get back to you
and second question
um thank you chair
um I'd like to talk about lighting
um a couple of years ago I raised the
issue a failing railing Lighting on the
bridge over the Bancroft lock and cancer
shanton May well remember that
this was rectified at the time I'm
afraid I have to report that the
lighting is now failing again so please
could this be addressed
thank you yes
right councilor Jenny um Council Ford
Council Jason okay
thank you chair um will the leader look
at um planning policies that compel
developers to include solar panels
on new build housing is a prerequisite
before applications are approved
I am sure that is something that will be
considered when we put the new local
plan together it gives us the
opportunity to review a whole number of
uh policies personally I think that's
quite sensible uh I am sure my colleague
councilor Pemberton will make sure that
is given serious consideration when we
are doing the new local plan
Council put together
um at the last regulatory committee
meeting it was noted that one Post in
the enforcement team will not be
replaced
does the leader agree that the
well-resourced enforcement department is
imperative if we want to ensure that any
alleged breach or conditions is swiftly
investigated and acted upon if
applicable
thank you councilor bertegella one of
the issues with enforcement is it's not
a statutory Service uh enforcement will
be reviewed as part of the budget
process but I would go back to one of
the constraints I've been mentioning uh
continuously today there is no money
councilor Alcock
and in these meetings for the past three
years
leader I'm sure you'll agree to agree
with me that housing associations and
sometimes their failings to our
residents is just not good enough
so many times this has been raised in
Council as I know that I'm not the only
counselor sitting here who receives
emails consistently about people who are
in a dire situation due to failings of
housing associations
leader I'm dealing now with
eight open complaints
with one particular Housing Association
in my ward they're all serious
complaints that have been going on for
more than 18 months
and even as a counselor I'm getting
fobbed off
I would like to stress to you as leader
please can this District Council step in
and start holding housing associations
to book when they go wrong
foreign
[ __ ] I also have had complaints about
the certain Housing Association
uh we have had various meetings with the
same Housing Association
um
the reality actually is we are limited
in the powers we have to actually compel
them to do anything
um and would offer an observation that
housing associations seem to be a bit of
a law unto themselves uh I think we will
take up the point and see if we can get
together with the Housing Association
and see if we can bring more pressure to
Bear having said that we've had numerous
meetings with them we have tried to
bring pressure to bear and at the moment
I think you are seeing the results
which are not terribly good
thank you
right Council Rock
the leader uh in response to my question
on the 11th of July after a Curtis
conversation both with himself and the
then portfolio holder councilor shenton
a subject matter which was similar to a
question earlier on but not quite the
same
and then in a further conversation
inside them we're a member of the South
and South turned up rather underdressed
as I recollect
um gave us a commitment
um
about data and on how the one two three
collections were working to set them
would receive assurances we would
receive that both in the presence of the
chief executive and the deputy chief
executive the answer to those questions
have not been yet forthcoming
um when will I get answers to those
questions please and I do thank him for
the Kurdish uh response in in both of
those dates thank you chairman
all right thank you councilor okay I do
apologize that you haven't had the
information uh it would be chased up
after this meeting and as soon as it's
available it will be sent to you
Council please
thank you thank you chair this is
actually an easy one for you I hope
um leader may I just say thank you to
the district council for becoming a hub
for receiving uh medical donations for
ambulance Aid and to the staff who
organized it uh very soon I will be
driving one of the ambulances to the
Polish Ukrainian border so I understand
the importance of this so I was
wondering if we could just ask that we
push our collection point because it's
still desperately needed the Medical Aid
thank you
all right I think we would all support
that councilor clave
castlebridge
possibly for all other councilors
we stand here and we often go on about
cost of living
and we talk about various ways to help
people
would the leader be willing to accept
the challenge
along with all other councilors that we
should within 28 days to today State be
able to submit a very helpful food
recipe type thing so we may all publish
as a collective group of counselors for
Christmas in order to help people along
because you know what it gives a little
bit of cheer if nothing else and that
and even better we should set that
budget we've got to do it for less than
three pounds and every counselor does it
gives the money towards charity
uh I I think councilor Bromwich I can't
accept that on behalf of all counselors
because they would probably be beaten up
uh I do think it's quite a good idea
though
unfortunately my cooking skills are
abysmal well we were just wondering
about that actually it might be a
double-edged sword that one cancer
bromish
but in a very interesting point thank
you
cancer Pemberton
um thank you chairman
um
giving consideration to the health and
well-being of all members particularly
the deputy leader will the cash will the
leader of the council please cancel his
subscription to The Economist Financial
Times
unfortunately councilman
I've just taken out a new three-year
subscription
yeah
thank you very much indeed
right thank you very much indeed
everybody uh item 17 is for information
only and that is the notion of notion of
motion the motion of uh update for uh
the plant life and that is deferred
pending a report from officers
and I will now move on to item 18 which
is the motion on notice of the water
resources and I would ask it's been
proposed by cancer junid and count ex
seconded by cancer uh
Harrison
uh this motion was proposed and second
will be debated so would you like to
start Castle tuner
yes this is um technical because what
the it I'm following on from something
that's um the LGA has actually raised
concerns about River pollution levels
and water supply supplies
um have started to impact on a number of
councils particularly in their planning
and their house building uh I believe
there are now 23 councils that have been
impacted by water neutrality and yet it
is essential that it is addressed that
we do have
um that in our planning documents that
water companies are and developers are
engaged on reducing water wastage and
pollution at source and I'm just wanting
to find a way in which this can be done
by this Council because drought is being
forecast now uh to to be continuing into
next year and I know that a lot of
farmers for example are going to really
struggle with with farming uh because of
the drought over this next winter and
pollution is having a major impact on
our rivers and habitats and yet things
can be done about it but we do need to
engage with the water companies and the
developers in order to be able to do
that so by working together we can do
what we can to find Solutions but what I
also would like to hear is that we would
like could put pressure on uh elsewhere
government etc etc to find more
long-term solutions to reduce pollution
at source and conserve water supplies
I'm normally associated associated with
raising concerns over flooding but water
resources and the lack of water
resources are equally as important and
we cannot given that we're doing a local
plan now that will have an impact for
the next 10 years I'm just very very
keen to make sure that we're doing all
within our power to address this as an
issue and I say it is a technical matter
that to make sure that it is properly
addressed I do acknowledge that there is
something in the course strategy in
existence now but certainly those 23
councils that have found
um that they can't move on on planning
at the moment have found that their plan
and have not been adequate so I'm just
making sure that our council is properly
prepared
servant do you want to respond
secondly I think it fell down this one
um yes I totally agree with the council
unit I think water is the best asset we
have and I do hope that this Council can
support this motion thank you
thank you any other members wish to
speak Council Pemberton
thank you chair I'm I'm responded on
behalf of the leader um uh members will
be aware that we have engaged the
process of developing a new local plan
with our colleagues in Warwick and
members particularly uh who've been on
the uh The Joint member groups will have
heard me banging on and on and on about
the lessons that we're going to learn
and one of the lessons that we're going
to learn from the previous course
strategy is that we need to engage
all of the stakeholders particularly
infrastructure providers
at the beginning of the process not at
the end of the process and I'm pleased
to say that
um working closely with John careford we
have done just that
we are in dialogue for example with
Western power distribution but
specifically as it relates to water how
it relates to water cycle how it relates
to conserving and making best use of
water and flood risk I can confirm that
we have already engaged with seven
Trends they responded to the initial
scoping consultation
officers have had meetings with seven
Trent where we start to talk at a high
and confidential level about
what does the future look like in terms
of ensuring
um security of water best use of water
and I'm pleased to say that they've
engaged positively with those
discussions they have been invited to
all of the stakeholder workshops they
are part of the consultation process
around the issues and options
consultation and as we move to that
stage and have a better understanding of
what the issues and options are that
will be the point at which we're having
more detailed discussions with all the
infrastructure providers around how we
deliver every piece of infrastructure
that supports the requirements for the
local plan
um
they will also be part of the
infrastructure working groups which are
invested as part of the local plan
process
um over and above that there is a
strategic flood risk assessment which
we're undertaking which is which seven
Trent are also part of and we are
commissioning a water cycle study so
that starts to talk to some of the
things that you've talked about
councilor junid to look at Supply and
quality issues
um but that to some degree is also
dependent upon where those development
locations are going to be so
um I would say therefore that actually
this is one of those things where we're
already on it
um I'd probably be saying through the
local plan that's the mechanism for
updating rather than some separate
report back to to cancel
um and it and with the forbearance of
councilor junid I'd probably say there's
not a lot more to be added as far as
that in the sense of uh yes we're on it
we recognize it and it will be reported
through the local plan process
development
thank you uh Council Jefferson
all right thank you chair I would just
say that I think it is really really
important to come see the water supply
particularly when we are looking through
to a plan that runs to 2015. it's all
too easy to take water supply for
granted and I think we're already
hearing about problems with the
infrastructure that can't meet the water
demands from some of the new
developments
one of the things I would say is that I
think there will need to be across the
UK some fairly substantial investment in
water supply and reservoirs so I am more
than comfortable in supporting this
notice of motion
Castle Rock
it was actually in the context of sewage
but um there is a bit of a I I welcome
what cancer Pemberton said because he
knows he and I were on that are on that
together other members are on the
working group the South or it's your
local Planet I endorsed everything he
said about it however the local plan
isn't going to happen tomorrow it's not
going to come it's not going to be made
tomorrow and and we have problems day to
day with
um how we deal with large planning
applications right now
and we get these responses from the
water authorities uh and as as with the
notes about sewage that I put around
the water authorities are hacks
I think we need to understand when those
responses come back as to what they mean
because the water authority is a
hamstrung by by the water and sewage's
acts and unlike other all the other uh
statutory responses they are not
empowered to say they can object to
anything and and the way uh
infrastructure works is backwards they
get their money afterwards so when a
development has occurred for 500 houses
or whatever it is they get their money
back by charging for the the sewage and
water afterwards and they have
investment plans that they have to put
in first which are out of control
they're private companies so there's a
real problem so I think what we need to
do as we are doing is to engage with
those authorities perhaps more
proactively and the meeting I had with
Jeremy Wright and seven Trent
he did say to them could we think of a
form of work called you second strength
think of a form of words when you
respond
to indicate there might be a problem
with this planning application there
might be a problem with it which is not
an objection but it hints to the
planning Authority and to the planning
officers under the plane or uh uh
planning committee that really think
very carefully before you grant that and
I know we're hamstrunged by how the the
planning regulations work but that's
something we should be doing right now
and I I'm looking at the planning policy
member here let's talk to John careford
and see what we can do about that today
because we're we're saving up problems
right now with every application we
grabbed thank you
County cattle would you like to speak
I I was going to suggest some five six
years ago we actually had seven Trends
in this room
uh giving a training evening to members
about their forecast water supply and
water usage reassuring members uh and
those others who attended
um that everything was hunky-dory for
the future
um I think given we have now gone
through a very different change in many
different areas it's been very helpful I
think as an addendum to what the deputy
heed were saying that we invite seven
trying to come back to this room uh and
explain how the projections they've set
out
five six years ago have changed and
whether they still have the same level
of confidence
um to deliver continue to live a walk
well fresh water supplies and
notwithstanding the sewage problem you
referred to
Council put together
thank you so the leader um has kept
saying during this meeting there is no
money there is no money
um that does he agree or does he think
that the catastrophic mini budget has
made things worse for the economic
outcome of our Council
foreign
it's nothing to do with it so please
ignore that one can I just pick up a
point if I may as someone who's had
personal experience in the water and
wastewater industry I worked in the
industry building water and treatment
plants and Wastewater treatments for 25
years
the plants themselves were fine it was
the go the the the authorities who are
actually running this and you say quite
rightly private companies and such like
now effectively and to be honest with
you uh it's mismanaged as well and I
can't say any more than that I mean it's
quite frustrating had been on the other
side of the fence seeing the the plants
that we put in were perfectly heavy put
and not not being operated correctly
I've got huge sympathy with you Castle
Rock because I know exactly what you're
you're feeling on there all right thank
you members um I'm going to now ask
councilor Jefferson so there's a special
favor to respond to this please
thank you
thank you it's been an interest in
debate and I think actually we are all
pretty much of one mind uh what I would
just like to do is propose that uh where
this notice emotion says with the report
back on
uh insert the words through the local
plan process because the reality
actually is as we go through the local
plan process there will be a lot of
things coming up about infrastructure
and water in particular and we could use
that process to make sure we could
report back in total
so
I'd welcome that except that I don't
want it to be too prolonged because a
local plan takes an awful long time if a
report is to come then please can it be
sooner rather than later I I think
councilor June we will report back at
the appropriate points as we go through
the process so it's not as though it
will come at the end of the process
because dialogue is going on all the
time
do I have a second to put that counselor
yes cancer
yes
I suppose the question is would this the
proposal and second to be willing to
amend their motion as suggested I'd be
willing to as suggested as long as you
keep to that's exactly what you said
that it won't
something that will be at the end of the
plan I want this to be at the beginning
rather at the beginning of the planet it
most definitely won't be just at the end
of the plan okay so you're happy to
accept the friendly Amendment
thank you very much indeed we have a
proposal of a second there all those in
favor
well I think that's unanimous thank you
very much indeed members
and a good debate and thank you so much
for that I really appreciate it
right I am the next item is the cost of
living motion
um as the chief executive has mentioned
in an email to everyone that contrary
what was published this motion once
proposed and seconded will be referred
to the cabinet for consideration and
Report without debate so I have
councilor pertigella is I guess still
proposing it yes chair thank you and
Council Roth are you still seconding it
thank you very much indeed then in that
case then thank you very much it will
now go to a cabinet for discussion there
thank you very much indeed
right
um
urgent business none
members thank you very much indeed for a
very good meeting I now call it close